the recent headlines say it all
hate-crimes rise 10 percent amid surge
in anti gay and transgender attacks UK
LGBT hate crime makes shocking reading
religious hate crime offenses in the UK
on the rise hate crimes double in five
years in England and Wales oz Brits have
never hated each other quite so much or
at least that's what the latest Home
Office hate crime statistics and
campaigners would have us believe but
don't be fooled
sometimes things really aren't what they
seem the obsession with so-called hate
crimes has seen a deranged broadening
and loosening of boundaries around what
can be criminalized as hair hair crimes
can be logged without a shred of
evidence as long as someone somewhere
anonymously
it required merely perceives a motive of
ill-will against a social group a
two-tier justice system sees that
harsher punishments are more likely to
be meted out to you guessed it hate
crimes but crime is crime and all of it
is bad but seriously we really are not
as divided as you imagine and I think
that there is a point here Michelle I'm
sometimes a bit troubled by the
inconsistency of the way the figures are
compiled what's included do we have
online and do we treat that in the same
way we treat physical assault and so on
but I think that simply saying this you
know there's nothing here move along
well okay but I don't think that the way
that you set it out seems to me
completely right perhaps what we ought
to be recognizing with these figures
whether we like the detail of them or
not is that in contrast to the old days
where if somebody abused you if you're a
woman or you were black what you tended
to do was basically not say anything to
anybody not complain because to some
extent that's what they're like or you
know nobody will believe me and so on
surely what these figures are telling us
is that actually more people are willing
to stand up for themselves and call them
out and I think that has to be a good
thing in a diverse society that actually
we had a better idea of when and how
this kind of hatred or abuse or assault
is taking place we can we can argue
about the detail but surely it must be
right but we know what's going on
absolutely and before I bring someone
else aim just to be absolutely clear my
point is not nothing to see here
everyone do what you want move along
that's not my point my point is that I
believe this narrative of hate crime is
almost now become a political tool to
create and nurture and and embed
organizations that are financially
profiting from this kind of narrative I
feel that the statistics and misleading
us in terms of how bad this situation
really is I believe that it's almost
become as I've just said are almost a
political weapon you look at things like
bricks a bricks it is regarded as this
thing that's unleash this xenophobic
thing across asset our country and I
don't believe it I do not believe and if
you actually before I expand this if you
look at the crime survey across England
and Wales who actually goes out and
talks to people that are victims of
crime they those statistics actually
show the opposite and they show that
genuine hair crimes which absolutely we
should be investigating that's in
decline over the last decade I feel this
is a classic case Michelle of you
wanting to say that there's no racism
and hate and so why don't we stop
measuring it and then it will go away
before you and be I really need to
correct you that is not it would make me
some kind of imbecile to suggest that
there is not racism in this country
there's absolutely racist out there
doing things that they need to be taken
to task for and punished I just want to
let you hear from an MP tan Manjeet
Singh deathy on who has pointed out how
existential racism has become in our
political times where
the Prime Minister finally apologized
for his derogatory and racist remark
racist remarks mr. speaker which have
led to a spike in hate crime Nick I hear
you saying that this is not what the
topics passion is because there's a
narrative here which I feel Michelle's
touching on which and you mentioned in
your intro which is that hate crimes can
be just someone in their head deciding
that they've experienced the hate crime
the reality is there are people up and
down the country who have lived with for
years and are continuing to live with
attacks based on their race or their
sexuality or their ethnicity and I can't
see why you wouldn't be supporting more
measures to record and take actually
goodnight before I bring no pain sorry
this is really gonna be brief just so
you because you seem to think that I'm
making up that this is something so let
me just reference the college of
policing their hair crime operational
guidance for recording purposes the
perception of the victim or any other
person is the defining factor in
determining whether an incident is a
hair incident or in recognizing the
hostility element of a hate crime the
victim does not have to justify or
provide evidence of their belief and
police officers of staff should not
directly challenge this perception
evidence of the hostility is not
required for an incident or crime to be
recorded as a hate crime or hair
incident that sums up my point I just
feel that all we need is a sense of
proportion Cressida dick cursor self
said Commissioner was a metropolitan
commissioner of the map that resources
are scarce and she would prefer us to
look into not hate crimes necessarily
online crime violent crimes that are
actually plaguing the streets but I do
think it's really important given what
Trevor said and you know the abuse of
women and attacks on women and
minorities in the past that that these
things are reported but not necessarily
given you no longer jail sentences and
consumed more resources than violent
crimes well I think I mean I think we
just take a little step back from the
let's call it the emotion that the
surrounds this cuz I think there are
practical issues here which I don't
think we have a kind of a collective
view about in our society so for example
the 103,000 or there abouts hate crimes
includes all sorts of things it includes
online messages
it includes shouting at people in the
street and it also includes people
smashing in your windows I I wonder if
in reality we should bracket all those
things together now that seems to me a
kind of useful discussion to have rather
than you know is it real and all that we
know that there are real things
happening of all this behind the
question how do we respond to it leave
it there thanks Trevor
it's not every day you get the chance to
have a snap with royalty so when it
happens you've got to make the most of
it I'm Lindsey Kelly to adjust that when
she bagged herself a pic with Prince
Harry at the launch of the UK's new
Invictus games team earlier this week
but the RAF veteran got herself into a
right royal pallava when she went to put
her arm around the Duke of Sussex and
accidentally touched his bottom rather
than keep calm and carrying on Lindsay
made the most of her VIP access and gave
the Prince a cheeky squeeze
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
but Harry was just thankful it wasn't
his crown jewels
Lindsay Kelley you are are straight
touch of the week I'm always I'm sorry
I off I'm sometimes pinched men's
bottoms and when he pinched a stranger's
bottom not a stranger well whose bottom
did you last pin I'm not telling you I
wanna know but what I think we do have a
huge double standard which is I think
women can do it now and men that men
can't that's all we've got time for this
week but don't forget you can join in
the debate just search for the pledge on
Twitter and the show is also available
as a podcast subscribe using Apple
podcast Spotify or whichever app you
prefer thanks for watching and we'll see
you next time
[Music]